JENNA TAYLOR: So today we
have chef Amelia Saltsman
with us-- distinguished author
of the "Santa Monica Farmers'
Market Cookbook"
which-- I don't know
if you guys have-- I love--
and the new "Seasonal Jewish
Kitchen."
So they let me play
today-- first time
I'm going to be back here.
Hopefully, we're going
to have a great time.
Thank you all for being here.
Thank you for joining us.
Welcome to Google.
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
Well, thank you for
that wonderful introduction.
[APPLAUSE]
My two favorite
words-- food literacy.
That is my passion.
And I learn right along with
everyone else as I do my work.
And then the result of that is
the "Seasonal Jewish Kitchen,"
my new cookbook, that really
took me one step-- no,
many, many, millennia
back to what we do today--
seasonal sustainable
cooking as a way
to make our lives easier,
simpler, healthier,
and, by the way,
save the planet.
It's all right there
in how we cook.
And what I discovered is that
that-- what we do today--
has really ancient roots--
really exciting to me.
That's my new food
literacy right here.
JENNA TAYLOR: To us, as well.
Yeah.
Very important to Google--
all of those things.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: So
what I want to do today
is I want to show you some
simple tricks and techniques
that are really going to
make that so much easier--
to get dinner on the table
at home after a busy day
and answer all those questions
we just talked about.
And I'm so delighted to
be cooking with you today.
JENNA TAYLOR: Me, too.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: I know--
girlfriends in the kitchen.
It's great.
Today we're going to do two
recipes from the "Seasonal
Jewish Kitchen"-- Yemenite
Pumpkin Carrot Soup-- well,
today we're doing a parsley
pesto to top it off.
And this is a Middle Eastern
tweak on a classic, kind of,
fall-winter soup.
Right?
And the other recipe
we're going to do
is an Apple, Fennel,
and Watermelon Radish
Salad-- refreshing, gorgeous
counterpoint to winter dishes,
if we actually got winter.
JENNA TAYLOR: Sounds amazing.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: So I think
we should get started.
JENNA TAYLOR: Let's go.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: So we're
going to start with the soup.
And I like to consider
this a master recipe.
I think everything
should be-- have
a template that you can then
use in a lot of different ways.
So we're always going
to start with aromatics.
We want to build flavor.
Jenna, if you want to
get the pot heated--
this nice, big, wide soup pot.
I think it's over here.
Yeah.
Right.
Oh, you know this stove well.
JENNA TAYLOR: Notoriously
tricky stoves.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Yeah.
So maybe--
JENNA TAYLOR: You
have to be smarter
than the average
Googler to use them.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: And we always
want to start with an onion.
Well, no.
We shouldn't say while
we start with an onion,
but if you eat onions,
it's a great way to start.
And I like to cut it in half.
And then you can just
peel back the layers.
And, Jenna, if you want
to cut an onion as well.
I think we'll just probably
used one in the soup
that we're cooking today.
And I like to simply cut-- I
leave the root end attached
protecting my fingers.
And then I turn
the onion and chop.
So we just need a gentle,
homestyle, medium chop
to our onion.
And I guess we'll make that a
dump bowl for compost later.
And once the pot is warm--
so we want to warm the pot,
and then we're going
to add our onion.
And we've also
gotten some celery.
Now, celery is a
really lovely aromatic.
Great celery has
a terrific flavor.
So let's start with oil.
We're going to use-- and
you think that's hot?
Well, we'll find out.
Let's see if the oil shimmers.
Why, yes, it is.
That's what you're looking for.
When the pot is hot
but not smoking,
you're going to get the oil--
it's going to liquify and start
to shimmer.
And when you put something in--
[SIZZLE]
[GASP]
--you'll get a nice sizzle which
will start flavors building.
So we're going to go
ahead and add celery.
And be sure to look for those
tender leaves in the middle.
The tender stocks that are
whiter and the pale green
leaves-- they add
a lot of flavor.
And we're going to add a
couple of chopped carrots.
I love this great combination
of carrots together with pumpkin
because what I find is
that the carrot really
balances the flavor
of the winter squash.
Sometimes squash can
be a little vegetal,
and this way it, sort of,
tones it down and really
makes it very nice.
And we finely chop them so they
can get lots of all around-- we
can develop color and
flavor right away.
So we're going to let
those cook-- medium heat.
We don't want them
to brown, but we
want them to get really soft.
And here's a simple trick.
Great cooking is as simple as
adding salt in layers-- salt
as you go.
So let's say you want a teaspoon
of salt in the whole recipe.
Maybe a quarter of a
teaspoon right now-- it's
very different than just
dumping a teaspoon at the end.
JENNA TAYLOR: I always
wonder about that.
Whether to-- I feel like
you salt ingredients
individually and then
layer the flavors.
But some say add it at the end.
I like the idea
of building it in.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Yes.
It really makes-- you try it.
Try the experiment.
We'll let that-- we
don't want-- we just
want to let it go gently.
And let's talk about the
squash that we're going to add.
So anybody ever try
to cut a raw squash?
[LAUGHS]
JENNA TAYLOR: You better
have a sharp knife,
or you're going
to hurt yourself.
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
Yeah-- not so easy.
So here's the trick-- a
home cooks' best trick.
Don't cut it.
Put it in a hot oven--
maybe 375-- something
like that-- whole
on a sheet pan.
You can protect it with foil
or a parchment, if you like.
Just shove that baby into
a hot oven until it's soft.
And then-- I think I'm going
to let you do the honors.
OK, Jenna?
I want you to just cut it.
You can use the
knife of your choice.
JENNA TAYLOR:
Right over the top?
Just, right-- the top off
or right in the middle?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Yeah--
right through the equator.
JENNA TAYLOR: Well, much easier
than last time I cut a squash.
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
Oh, look at that.
OK.
Can you all see?
You all got a good look?
So then-- let's see.
I'm going to grab a spoon.
Then it's really a
very simple matter
to simply scoop out the seeds.
Oh, look at that.
You can save the
seeds, of course,
if you like to roast or plant.
And then you can
now-- this recipe
would call for 3 cups of squash
which I would prefer weighing.
So you just scoop it right onto
a scale till you get to-- oh,
we're in grams.
So we're going to
do about 750 grams.
I don't know if
we're going to have
enough in this small
squash but that'll be fine.
So there you go--
instant squash puree.
JENNA TAYLOR: And do you need to
prick it or anything like that?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Nothing.
JENNA TAYLOR:
Literally, throw it in.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Just
literally throw it in.
You might wipe it down
if its got a lot of dirt
from the garden.
But that's it.
That's it.
JENNA TAYLOR: Would that work
for a spaghetti squash, do you
think?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: It would.
It works for any squash.
Now, the smaller
squashes you can easily
cut in half-- like
a butternut squash.
Those aren't that
hard to cut in half.
And those would be--
JENNA TAYLOR: Like a
pumpkin or something?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Right.
JENNA TAYLOR: Big
acorn squash or--
AUDIENCE: You said 375
degrees for how long?
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
Oh, until it's soft.
So it might take-- like, this
might have taken an hour.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AMELIA SALTSMAN: The
question was, how long?
So that's the
thing about dealing
with the properties
of natural foods--
whole foods-- which is that
every one is a little bit
different.
This might be drier.
It might be more dense.
It might be more watery.
But you do want to look
for a squash like this
that-- like a kabocha--
something like that that
has a lot of starch and
not a lot of water--
not a Halloween-- well,
we'll have this ready to go.
JENNA TAYLOR: Great.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Not
a jack-o-lantern.
JENNA TAYLOR: So after
carving, don't cook it.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Well, those
aren't designed for cooking.
There are a lot of great
squashes out there that are.
So we can see what's happening
here is that we're developing.
The color is heightening,
if you can see.
And it's really telling us that
it's bringing the flavor out.
JENNA TAYLOR: Smells amazing.
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
Already, you know?
So we can add-- you can also
make the soup with raw cut
up squash if you
have a strong friend.
OK-- a lot of work.
JENNA TAYLOR: Do you find
there's any difference
texturally, or in
timing-wise, or anything
if you're doing it with raw?
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
You know, I prefer
to cook with something
roasted because I've already
caramelized the flavors.
And I had reduced
the moisture so
that I have the natural sugars
concentrated in flavors.
And I think that is one
of another key trick.
It's not hard to do.
JENNA TAYLOR: Roasting
vegetables is perhaps
my favorite kitchen technique.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: It is.
It is.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's so easy,
and it's so delicious.
And you can do it
with everything.
And everybody's always
like, I've never
had [INAUDIBLE] vegetable
this tasty before.
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
That's exactly right.
You need one sheet pan, a
little bit of olive oil,
some great salt, and then
the world's your oyster.
JENNA TAYLOR: Pretty
much-- whatever
is at the farmers'
market-- roast it.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Right.
And it all tastes different.
JENNA TAYLOR: And
it's all delicious.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: All right.
So I think we're ready
for our next step.
JENNA TAYLOR: OK.
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
So now, we've built
our first layer of flavor.
We're going to add
the squash, and we're
going to add some seasoning.
We're going to add
a little more salt.
So, Jenna, if you want
to give a little-- now,
what makes this soup
a Yemenite soup,
in particular, is the blend
of spices that were used.
And this is hawaij which is a
Yemenite blend of coriander,
and cumin, and black pepper.
Black pepper is
used a lot in Yemen
but also turmeric which
adds a yellow color.
Let's see.
What else?
Turmeric-- cloves,
you might have.
So it's this very--
JENNA TAYLOR: Fragant?
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
--very fragrant,
aromatic-- I wouldn't quite go
to floral but getting there.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: --and
really distinctive.
And so we're creating
a simple soup,
and yet we're elevating it
a little bit with something,
maybe, we don't eat every day.
JENNA TAYLOR: Squash in?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Squash in and
let's give a good dose of this.
Now, if you don't
have hawaij, which
is available in Middle Eastern
stores, buy-- basically,
use a mix of coriander, and
cumin, and black pepper.
And you'll be good to go.
So again, layering flavor--
we're bringing it up.
By cooking it, we haven't
added any liquid yet.
JENNA TAYLOR: Smells amazing.
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
Can you all smell?
JENNA TAYLOR: Oh man.
Sense waves flying
out to all of you.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: All right.
And now, we're going
to ladle in some stock.
Now, if you can,
heat the stock first.
It'll get your
cooking going faster.
If you don't have time, you
don't want to use the pot--
don't.
We can add--
JENNA TAYLOR: Just
chicken stock?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Right.
And we're using vegetable
stock, so this is a soup
that just happens to be vegan.
JENNA TAYLOR: Oh,
vegan-- I love it.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: I
love added value.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah, absolutely.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: We go for
flavor first and then added
value.
So chicken stock would be great.
That would make it
even more Yemenite.
JENNA TAYLOR: Savory.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: --savory
and that Yemenite quality.
So we're going to
add about 4 cups.
JENNA TAYLOR: OK.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: And we're
going to let that simmer.
And here's another
home cook trick.
While something is simmering--
long task-- unattended--
do something else.
So we're going--
JENNA TAYLOR: Time management.
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
Time management.
The next thing we're going
to do is make our pesto.
So this lovely condiment
will dress up a soup.
It'll dress up a lot of things.
It's very nice.
You can make it either
with-- thank you, Chef.
You can either make it with
parsley, as we're doing today,
or cilantro which
is very, very nice.
So a good handful of
leaves-- I would say,
maybe, a 1/4 cup packed.
And I think what
we're going to do is--
JENNA TAYLOR: Do I need to
turn this down for simmer?
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
We're going to-- well,
we'll bring it up
to a good simmer.
And, you know what?
Let's throw in a
handful of these.
Now, here's another
little trick.
When they're whole and
you cook them down,
they will just get sweeter.
JENNA TAYLOR: Melty.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Melty
sweet as opposed to chopping
and releasing all of
those-- all of the pungency.
So we're going to add a couple
of cloves of garlic here.
I think I'm going to give
them a rough chop first.
So this is a very
simple condiment.
And you'll notice,
really, that we
are-- other than the spice
mix-- we are flavoring food
with food.
We are using the ingredients
from the farmers' market.
JENNA TAYLOR: I
love that way to say
it-- flavoring food with food--
not additives-- other food.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Exactly.
JENNA TAYLOR: That was simple
but a little bit profound
these days, when
you think about it.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Mm.
And we need about
a teaspoon of salt.
We're making a nice condiment.
And we'll take the olive oil.
And is this plugged in, Chef?
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah--
looks like it.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: OK.
So we're going to work in--
oh, about 1/3 or 1/2 cup
of olive oil.
And if you want to
start grinding that up.
JENNA TAYLOR: Throw the
outboard motor in there?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Mm-hmm.
JENNA TAYLOR: All right.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Stick blender--
another cook's favorite tool.
[BLENDER GRINDING]
This will keep.
So I love using this.
This will keep in
your refrigerator.
I would make a double,
triple batch of this
and just use it on
grilled chicken--
just wherever you need a hit.
And it's going to be our
final flavor layer on the top.
And I want to get our apple--
our salads [INAUDIBLE].
You know, we forgot to
add parsley to the soup.
I'm just going throw in this.
Oh, you know, this is how you
cook it [INAUDIBLE]-- parsley.
JENNA TAYLOR: Looks
perfect to me.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Can you all
see how gorgeous that is?
JENNA TAYLOR: What kind--
are we-- texturally-- Chef,
is this texturally
what we're going for?
Do we need to emulsify it more?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Yes.
No, I think that's lovely.
Easy to drizzle-- just lovely.
So we'll set that aside.
So this is ready to go on
our soup when it's done.
So let's make our salad.
You ready?
JENNA TAYLOR: Yes ma'am.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Really great
tool-- do you use this tool?
JENNA TAYLOR: Love.
Love-- just don't
get your finger.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Oh,
I'm going to show
you a trick for that, too.
OK.
And I like to work
right into the bowl,
so we'll leave that here.
And we'll start with radishes.
So this is our apple, fennel,
and watermelon radish salad.
And I get so tired of people--
it's, like, oh, it's December.
I can't get good tomatoes.
I don't know what to do.
Right?
Well, buy what's ready.
And there are so
many salads to have.
Watermelon radishes--
what a surprise inside.
Sometimes it's nice to
give them a little peel
if we have-- here we go-- one
to you-- because sometimes it
releases the pretty
color so it really does.
It doesn't taste
like a watermelon.
It looks like a watermelon,
but it's a lovely radish.
And, you know, we
eat with our eyes.
JENNA TAYLOR: Just got one of
these in my CSA box this week.
It's the perfect excuse
to do this salad.
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
Well, and you know
what I love about a
CSA box is-- first
of all, besides supporting your
local farmers who certainly
need our help.
Don't they-- with
this crazy climate?
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah-- with
the drought, especially.
Yeah.
But it forces me to--
well, not "forces"
but it gives me an excuse to
cook things I might not have
necessarily cooked before or
that I wouldn't-- might be
intimidated to pick up at the
store or the farmers' market.
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
Well, and I think
that's a very good
point because there
are so many things-- people
say, oh, we don't have that.
And I'm thinking--
JENNA TAYLOR: You probably do.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: You
just never noticed it.
It was hiding in plain sight.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: So these are
quite large, but you can see--
JENNA TAYLOR: Oh, pretty.
Has everybody seen the inside
of a watermelon radish--
so incredibly beautiful.
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
I mean, why not?
Look at what nature
has given us.
We might as well take advantage.
Thank goodness the farmers
are giving it to us.
JENNA TAYLOR: And
all radishes are not
white and red little
globes of crunchiness.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: So
these radishes already
had their stems removed,
but what I like to do
is leave an inch of
the stem attached.
That's your handle.
JENNA TAYLOR:
That's your handle?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Natural handle.
JENNA TAYLOR: Love it.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: So we'll
just stop a little early.
So then what happens is this
tool makes for fast slicing
but also wonderful texture.
It's thin.
It's lovely.
So when you taste the salad,
you're going to have all this
wonderful contrast in each
bite-- the pungent radish--
JENNA TAYLOR: And
uniform, right?
So if you are doing like a
gratin or something where you
need all your slices to be--
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Well,
now you're getting fancy.
JENNA TAYLOR: Well, I'm just
saying-- seasonal dishes.
If you want to give us a
couple of radishes into there.
And here you go, if
you finish those.
I'm going to start with the
next flavor component-- fennel.
So now we have some great,
big bulbs of fennel.
And can I have
that scissors back?
Can somebody reach
me that scissors?
Thank you.
So, again, flavoring
food with food.
Here is our fennel bulb.
You might say, well,
what does this have to do
with seasonal Jewish cooking?
Well, fennel is,
actually, traditionally,
a rich vegetable.
It may be--
JENNA TAYLOR: Is it really?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: It is.
It may be iconic
to Italian cooking,
but it wasn't until the
beginning of the 19th century
that it became a mainstream
Italian food which I think
is kind of interesting.
JENNA TAYLOR: It's fascinating.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Food
literacy-- new factoid.
So it's got a sweet and
slightly licorice quality to it.
So it's really different.
It's very complex.
And, of course, the
fronds are lovely.
We're going to be able
to save some of those
and use them in our salad.
So, again, we're going
to remove this for now.
I've already left my handle--
going to cut it in half.
If it has a big tough core,
you can cut some of that out.
And then I like to remove the
tougher, outer layers to make
for a more tender salad.
And this happens to have lobes.
And then we're ready to
grate, and this is my handle.
JENNA TAYLOR: Oh, great.
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
[INAUDIBLE], OK.
There you go.
JENNA TAYLOR: Right in
here with these radishes?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Right in there,
we're making the salad right
into the bowl.
And I'll just get
those ready for you.
OK.
There you go.
And I'm going to move
right on to the apples.
So now, we've got this,
sort of, slightly licorice,
crisp, crunchy fennel going on.
And now, of course, our lovely--
these look like pink ladies.
JENNA TAYLOR: Mm.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: One
of my favorites--
so we're going to get the sweet,
tart, and beautiful color.
Trick-- trick alert--
to core an apple quickly
for this purpose-- I'm
going to cut it in half.
I'm going to cut it in quarters.
And then I'm just going
to cut out the core.
OK?
Without another knife.
JENNA TAYLOR: Very, very cool.
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
Very cool, right?
And so then that's
just ready to cut
into these wonderful
little pieces.
So we'll use a couple of apples.
And then the other piece we're
going to put in this salad
is-- we're going to use some
lovely winter salad greens.
Now, you know, leafy things--
there's more than lettuce.
There's more than lettuce.
So in winter we have a lot--
it's really fascinating to me
because in winter we have leafy
greens that taste like winter.
You know?
They're a little meatier.
They're heartier.
They might have spice to
them-- all the things we
like at this time of the year.
And when we add those to a
salad and we're serving them
with winter fare--
hearty stew-- things
like that-- it just feels right.
And one of the
things that I noticed
when I was doing the
book is that the foods
that we want to eat--
that we gravitate
toward during the
holiday season tend
to be the foods, historically,
that, of course, are in season.
We just kind of lost track
somewhere along the line.
JENNA TAYLOR: With the
way food is sold today,
it's very easy to misunderstand
what is and isn't in season,
especially if you don't look
at where it's coming from.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Precisely.
Precisely.
And that's why it's
really important for us
to educate ourselves and to
really use all our senses-- use
our smarts.
We forget when it comes
to food-- sometimes
we don't trust our instincts.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah.
If the tomatoes are
white, it's probably
not the time to buy a tomato.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: You think?
You think?
JENNA TAYLOR: Whatever
looks and smells
the best is probably in season.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: So I'm going
to add just some of the this.
I think we're good.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Yeah.
I think we've got--
JENNA TAYLOR: Beautiful.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: So I'm going
to use the best stirring tool
known to man and womankind.
JENNA TAYLOR: Everybody
has two of them.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: I'm gauging
what I want to do here.
I don't want this to be a green
salad with a few little things.
I want lots of texture.
So I've looked to see how
much-- what my balance is.
But you can see
what's happening.
JENNA TAYLOR: Is it, maybe,
equal parts of everything?
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
Something like-- I
would say we would prefer
two-ish of everything
and then a couple of
handfuls-ish of everything.
JENNA TAYLOR: Greens?
OK.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: And
we're going to go
with that other lovely autumn
and winter essence-- walnuts--
toasted walnuts.
And you know why you toast them?
You toast them to
develop flavor.
How's our soup doing?
JENNA TAYLOR: It looks glorious.
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
So a nice handful--
toast them-- 350 degrees--
about 10 minutes.
The flavor comes up.
The aroma comes
up-- you'll know.
I like to season a
salad right in the bowl.
You don't need to
make another dressing.
You don't need another bowl.
A couple of good
squeezes-- all you
need is a tablespoon
or two of oil.
You can always add more.
JENNA TAYLOR: And walnut
oil, in this case?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Walnut
oil which I love.
Be sure and get a
good one because it's
a flavor component.
And let's see-- salt. Now,
I'm using kosher salt here,
but what would be really nice
is a crunchy, finishing salt
like Maldon or fleur de sel,
but Maldon is particularly nice.
Again, generous pinch or two
and you can always add more.
And flavoring food
with food-- five hole
zester-- not a big deal, but
it does this wonderful thing.
Do it right over the salad.
It releases-- I
can see the spray.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah-- sprang up.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Yeah.
Can you smell it--
even from there, right?
And it just adds this beautiful,
beautiful long strands.
It's beautiful, but it's
adding flavor and mouth feel.
Then we can just give a
nice squeeze of lemon.
And that, my friends,
is the salad dressing.
Do we have something that
we're going to toss this
with besides our hands?
JENNA TAYLOR: I'm sure.
A couple of wooden
spoons, or some tongs,
or what do we think?
Thank you.
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
And meanwhile, I'm
going to give a little hair
cut with these wonderful fronds
right into the salad.
You can save the
rest of the fronds
for using with
fish-- wrapping fish.
It's wonderful.
JENNA TAYLOR: Ooh, wrapping
fish-- that's a fun one.
Oh, this smells so
bright and fragrant.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: It really
is a lovely component
of a winter meal.
JENNA TAYLOR: I'm seeing my
Christmas salad come together.
[LAUGHS]
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Oh,
the options are endless.
JENNA TAYLOR: Well, I
knew I wanted something
with these notes.
Now I can say, I learned
it from a professional.
[LAUGHS]
AMELIA SALTSMAN: You know, let's
make it even more beautiful.
If we take one of those
platters-- and then what
I think is wonderful-- I
think a salad is so beautiful
mounted so that you
really can appreciate
every beautiful thing that
you've put in this salad,
right?
And, oh, look at
that wonderful lemon.
It's just drifting
off everywhere.
JENNA TAYLOR: Really beautiful.
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
Isn't that nice?
JENNA TAYLOR: And so easy.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: OK.
So now, we've got
our salad ready.
And this salad-- the nice thing
about winter ingredients--
this salad can sit.
You can just make it.
It'll be fine for an hour or
so while you do something else.
It'll be fine even for a couple
hours which is really nice.
So meantime, let's
finish our soup.
So what we've got--
well, this looks pretty
[INAUDIBLE] but we can finish.
Let's see.
Let's take a taste and
see what we've got.
OK.
So by the magic of Chef Didi--
JENNA TAYLOR: Ooh.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: We
are going to-- so we're
going to puree this one.
JENNA TAYLOR: OK.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: All right.
So let's see, we need
our stick blender.
JENNA TAYLOR: Gotcha.
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
And I don't know
how hot this is underneath.
No, it's fine.
JENNA TAYLOR: Wherever you like.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Well,
wherever we have a good visual.
Can you all see what
we're doing here?
All right.
Yes?
No?
Move it?
[LAUGHS]
JENNA TAYLOR: Slide under there.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JENNA TAYLOR: We'll
move it over there.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: All right.
JENNA TAYLOR: Let's move to this
one so we can-- there we go.
All right.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: So, again,
we can-- so we're just-- now,
you can see this soup-- Chef
made this with the raw squash.
So you can see we have these
nice soft cubes of squash
that have given their
all to the soup.
And let's see--
[BLENDER GRINDING]
--and just puree
right in the pot.
And we're going to
need our soup bowls.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yes.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: So as
you puree this soup,
if it feels like it's
too thick then you
can thin it with more--
JENNA TAYLOR: More stock.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Mm-hmm.
[BLENDER GRINDING]
Yeah.
JENNA TAYLOR: Consistency-wise--
this one is much thicker.
Which are we going for?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Well,
somewhere in between-- I
haven't finished
pureeing this one.
So this one I'd probably--
JENNA TAYLOR: Little
bit more stock?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: --be
adding more-- right.
I would be adding more stuff.
You can always add more, but
if you start with too much,
then you have boiled vegetables.
[LAUGHING]
[BLENDER GRINDING]
OK.
You can do this in a blender--
in a regular stand blender.
But I'm going to need that
spatula so we can plate this.
[METAL CLANKING]
JENNA TAYLOR: Ladle, spatula?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Ladle-- sorry.
So now we have our
beautiful soup.
The thing about
using a stand blender
is that you have
more to wash, and you
have to wait until the
soup cools off a little.
You have a little
more-- you don't
want it to explode on you.
So here we go.
Doesn't that just
look like autumn?
JENNA TAYLOR:
Smells [INAUDIBLE].
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Yeah.
And then why don't we drizzle
a little bit on there?
Yeah-- just feel
your inner Picasso.
Great.
[LAUGHTER]
JENNA TAYLOR: [INAUDIBLE].
It's a little excited.
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
And there we go.
So this last layer of
flavor has built it
so that it's not the same
as if we had made the soup
and put it inside.
It just when we eat it--
which is ready now--
it just adds a lot more magic.
And it's not hard to do.
And it's so pretty.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah.
And I love doing the pesto right
in the jar-- speaking of not
washing more things or having
a food processor-- my food
processor has so many
pieces, and then you
have to wash them all.
That's brilliant.
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
Anyway, so that's it.
JENNA TAYLOR: And
it looks beautiful.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: All right.
So here we are.
Aren't we clever?
JENNA TAYLOR: Excellent.
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Any questions?
JENNA TAYLOR: Questions?
What's the best way to
make vegetable stock?
Right.
And make it tasty
because no offense but--
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Great question.
So in the book I do have a
recipe for a simple vegetable
stock.
Two things-- you can
either make it the way
we started the soup-- saute
all the ingredients first
and add the water in batches.
Again, avoiding the
boiled vegetable taste.
JENNA TAYLOR: So
layer in liquid.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Right.
Add the liquid-- half of the
liquid-- you can add more
and just let it be
very concentrated.
If you want to take
a little more time,
our other favorite technique--
roast the vegetables first
for about 45 minutes, so
you've got some browning.
It'll make a more robust stock.
And then start your soup.
Then put it in a pot and cook
it-- again, adding enough salt
and allowing it to be
dense with vegetable.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah.
What vegetables actually form
your base for your stock?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: The stock-- OK.
What are the vegetables
for the stock?
Certainly onions, carrots,
celery, parsley, and then
leeks, in addition-- which
are not quite the same
as onions, right?
So adding a sweetness-- keep
those green tops in there.
A piece of butternut
squash is great,
a couple of tomatoes
or sun dried tomatoes
to give you umami-- that
sort of meaty quality.
JENNA TAYLOR: Mushroom
[INAUDIBLE] dried or--
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
I was just going
to say a few dried mushrooms
would be excellent.
You can add a lot of things.
You can add pea
tendril tops, pea--
JENNA TAYLOR: Shoots-- yeah?
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
--shoots and so on.
But anything that's
very odiferous--
I wouldn't put broccoli
or cauliflower.
They're too strong.
If you want to use the
woody ends of asparagus,
that's fine--
particularly if you're
making an asparagus
soup-- very flavorful.
JENNA TAYLOR: Layer
that in, right?
In the base?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: But it's
very flavorful so-- but,
yes, lots of vegetables.
JENNA TAYLOR: So
lots of freedom.
Riff on it.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Yes.
What you have in
the house will work.
JENNA TAYLOR: The citrus.
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
Isn't that nice?
It just pops, so you've
got a lot of contrast
in color, flavor, and texture.
JENNA TAYLOR: Yeah.
I feel like acid is one
of those elements that
will take a dish next level
and really impress your friends
and family.
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
Just enough acid.
JENNA TAYLOR: Just
so that hint--
that bright hint of acid.
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
Yes, and that is key.
I think that's one of the
things we don't think about when
we make salads which is we
over dress, we over vinegar,
and we get very complicated.
And if we have
flavorful ingredients,
we should just get
out of their way.
JENNA TAYLOR: Simple.
Simple.
AUDIENCE: How long do
you roast the walnuts?
JENNA TAYLOR: How long
do you roast walnuts?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: At 350-- I
would say 5 to 10 minutes.
I would check them after five,
but you really-- probably
at 350, it would probably
take close to 10 minutes.
You want them to be fragrant.
And when you cut
into one, you should
see a little bit of color.
They will continue to cook
from their own residual heat.
They have a lot of oil.
So once you take
them out of the oven,
they're going to
continue to brown.
And you want them to have
color but not to be dark.
JENNA TAYLOR: I almost
always burn the first batch.
It's one of those tasks--
you can't get distracted when
you're doing it because it'll
go from perfect to yucky
in about a second.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: And I
like to do it in the oven.
I think you have
the most control.
And I think also you have--
JENNA TAYLOR: --surface
area exposed to heat.
Yeah.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Exactly.
Exactly.
And that's really a
key for any roasting.
One of the things we should
talk about-- size matters.
So you noticed we
used a wide pot.
So when you have wide, you
have a lot of surface area.
You have a lot of
evaporation and a lot
of flavor concentration.
When you're making
the vegetable stock
and you want to have
a lot of liquid,
a deeper pot is
usually more helpful.
Same thing when you're
roasting vegetables.
Nice, big-- those
half sheet pans
we were using--
your best friend.
And leave room--
if you pile them
one on top of the other--
the vegetables one on top
of the other, you're
going to steam them.
So in the "Santa Monica
Farmers' Market Cookbook,"
I actually wrote an entire four
page roasting vegetable primer.
JENNA TAYLOR: Love it.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Because
it's the same technique
but each vegetable
sometimes has a little bit--
JENNA TAYLOR: Little tweaks.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Little tweaks--
they have their own nature.
For instance, certain
dense vegetables that are
fibrous like
cauliflower or broccoli.
I think they're
better if you blanch
them first-- so to boil
them in salted water
for a couple of minutes.
It might seem like
an extra step,
but the result is going to
be tender yet crisp and not
dry and chewy.
So it's worth it.
And you can do that
step a day or two ahead,
and then you have
convenience food.
JENNA TAYLOR: Didn't even
think of that-- brilliant.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Yeah.
Food literacy.
[LAUGHTER]
JENNA TAYLOR: Learn
something every single time.
Oh, beautiful
question-- what did you
discover about
yourself when you were
writing this book
despite how you've
been cooking for forever?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Well, it really
was an extraordinary journey.
I have been cooking
the seasonal way,
teaching, and hoping to
help people learn that as we
struggle through
our busy lives--
that supporting our local
farmers and cooking this way
is the answer to a whole lot.
And when I started looking
through the lens of how
I cook for the
Jewish holidays, I
realized I didn't change my
approach to all that we've just
been talking about today.
And I thought,
oh, wait a minute.
There's something here.
And as I started to explore,
I really realized-- I mean,
I understood that I had
access to seasonal ingredients
for those particular holidays.
I don't know how
many of you celebrate
any of the Jewish holidays, but
it was more than just, oh, yes.
They're in season now.
I began to see how the
synchronicity of what
we do seasonally,
and sustainably,
and how the ancient lessons
are-- they're already there
in-- I reread "The Bible"
for agriculture and food.
JENNA TAYLOR: Wow.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: And
it's all right there.
And having nothing
to do with religion
but having to do with history,
and reading, and remembering we
didn't invent
everything yesterday.
And sometimes it's
good to remember.
JENNA TAYLOR: Absolutely.
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
And what happened
is that it expanded that
sense that I already
had of being grateful to
the farmers who grow my food
and expanding that to
an even greater degree--
that "The Seasonal
Jewish Kitchen, A Fresh
Take on Tradition" is really
about a global patchwork
of really interesting
regional cuisines.
Jewish or not,
people tend to think
that Jewish cooking is deli, you
know, matzah ball soup-- things
like that.
But it's so much more.
It's an entire world of food.
And the European tradition that
we know so well in this country
is just one aspect.
And I really wanted to just
open up that box-- that way
of thinking.
And I hope you'll take a
look and enjoy the book.
JENNA TAYLOR: All right.
Well, thank you all for
being here with us today.
Thank you so much for your time.
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
Well, and thank you.
I had a great time cooking.
JENNA TAYLOR: Oh, me, too.
Me, too.
Absolutely-- hopefully, you'll
come back and see us again.
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
I would love to.
JENNA TAYLOR: Great.
[APPLAUSE]